question number one and the only question
for this session okay the question is pastor
skeet is it okay to watch movies as long
as they are not r-rated what about movies
about jesus is it okay to watch movies as long as
they're not what uh r-rated r-rated are rated okay
the bible says in philippians chapter four verse
eight finally brethren whatsoever things are true
whatsoever things are honest whatsoever
things are just whatsoever things are pure
whatsoever things are lovely whatsoever things
out of good report if there be any virtue if
there be any praise think on these things when
we make decisions as to what will enter our
minds because once something gets into your mind
you cannot get it out now you can seek divine
wisdom to control its influence but it is best
not to allow certain things to enter our minds
now if you are a christian and i suppose the the
the question comes from a christian the chris the
que the christian always has to consider is this
to the glory of god first corinthians 10 31 says
whether therefore ye eat or drink or whatsoever
ye do what you watch what you hear what you wear
do all for the glory of god now
this is an individual matter
and i am not legislating for anyone but i'm
simply saying the christian functions by different
standards all together the christian standards of
recreation standards of play standards of social
interaction standards of boy girl relationships
they are vastly different from the world
now if you're one of those christians who
happen to be half and half you know we
have african-americans italian americans irish
americans chinese americans and then you have
christian non-christian you have vegetarian
meat eater we have all these combinations
if you're one of those then you can watch anything
you like but if you're a genuine child of god
you've got to be careful what you allow to enter
your mind proverbs 4 23 says keep thine heart with
all diligence the heart being the mind keep
it guard it that's the same word used in the
genesis when god told adam dress the garden
and keep it it's the same word used when
the bible says remember sabbath they keep it
holy we must keep our minds with all diligence
for out of it are the issues of life all possible
diligence we must guard our mind whether the movie
is about jesus or not we must also remember that
god judges an action based on the motive behind it
movies are made for financial reasons whether
it's the passion of christ the last temptation
of christ or the first temptation
movies are made for business reasons
and so my response to you is whatsoever things
are true honest just pure lovely of good report if
there be any virtue if there be any praise think
on these things and do all to the glory of god